although most of the dead poor to hype
is focused on keyboard the film will
also see the debut of another marvel
mutant mercenary Domino a longtime ally
of cable and Deadpool Domino has spent
the last couple of decades in comics
shooting stabbing and punching away
through any threat
aided by her ability to influence
probability in her favor I didn't become
an x-man to play it safe besides our
side but there's a lot more to this
femme fatale than a bit of good luck and
a full magazine he is the untold truth
of Domino fake-out appearance any x-men
fan worth their salt knows that clones
and doppelgangers are practically a rite
of passage if you're trying to run with
xavius crew everyone from Jean Grey to
Cable has been subjected to a litany of
bizarre contrived sci-fi tropes over the
course of their time of the team on a
surprising note Domino actually has a
pretty straightforward history albeit
with one exception of first appearance
and comics in the grand scheme of things
Domino appears for the first time in New
Mutants issue 98 alongside Deadpool if
you want to get technical though
Domino's real debut as x-force issue 8c
it's revealed that the Domino B meet in
New Mutants issue 98 is actually the
shapeshifter mutant copycat
aka Vanessa Carlysle it isn't until
several issues later that the real
Domino reveals herself it's appropriate
really there's nothing more
quintessentially x-men than a
doppelganger and Domino covered that
base immediately upon her debut colossal
fling in the wake of the crossover story
Avengers vs. x-men Domino finds herself
joining cables newest spin-off team
x-force the team members and our
fugitives on the run from The Avengers
and many characters are trying to cope
of the fallout of the cataclysmic war
and Avengers vs. x-men Colossus in
particular finds himself grieving the
loss of his relationship with Kitty
Pryde enter Domino who quickly hits it
off of the big guy the new relationship
doesn't last long
leaving the fling is little more than a
strange a brief footnote in both of
their lives
original 6 buck colossus aside most
comics readers are more used to seeing
Domino work of the time-traveling mutant
cable the two have a long history
together as best friends teammates and
sometimes love interests cable and
Domino first met as members of the
mercenary team six-pack formerly known
as wild
back even after the six-pack disbanded
cable and Domino found themselves
sticking together eventually cable
joined the New Mutants team which later
became x-force and got Domino her gig
with the group birthday gift one of
Domino's most interesting relationships
is with Wolverine sometimes it's a
friendship sometimes a rivalry and other
times has even been a full-fledged
relationship one of the highlights of
their time together was when Domino
bought Wolverine a car for his birthday
it happens in the comic miniseries
x-force sex and violence the story wraps
up with Wolverine realizing that
Domino's secretly kept 37 million
dollars that was supposed to go to
charity right as he's about to get mad
she rolls up outside with a pristine
classic Mustang and wishes him a happy
birthday it's a little sleazy and a
little sweet the perfect combination for
Domino and Wolverine as they drive off a
wolverine realizes Domino has stashed
their nemesis razor fist in the trunk we
guess she can only do so many nice
things in a single day Domino versus
punisher there are few people in the
Marvel Universe more terrifying than
Frank Castle it's telling that the guy
doesn't have a single superpower and
still hasn't been taken down by a single
super hero who's tried to end his
vigilante days still it hasn't stopped
people from trying and one of those
people is Domino in Punisher War Journal
Domino goes after castle because he's
been accused of massacring civilians
tasked with taking him down by an old
acquaintance Domino is the only person
on the team who maintains that castle is
probably innocent he turns out to be
right and the climax sees the Punisher
duking it out with the real criminal
behind the crime jigsaw just as I served
which is great and all but we don't get
to find out who would win between these
two warriors in a head-to-head brawl
family reunion in the 2003 miniseries
Domino we find out that Domino gained
her skills as a mercenary through
project Armageddon a program designed to
create the perfect weapon she was
considered a failure and her mother went
on to break her out of the project after
that her mother disappeared
he is into a career as a mercenary
Domino meets a boy named Lazarus who has
the same distinctive eye marking
Ishida's Lazarus is revealed to be
Domino's half brother and as it turns
out he's the perfect weapon
unfortunately their mom isn't quite so
keen on their kids hanging out with a
crew of violent religious zealots she
sets out to put an end to both of them
Domino is forced to shoot her mom to
protect Lazaro
making this the worst family reunion in
history stripe surprise perhaps no other
x-men character better embodies the
spirit and aesthetic of the 90s and
strife he's a clone of cable from the
future whose suit is made of giant
knives more or less being an x-men
character there are plenty of alternate
universe versions of strife and an
x-force vol 2 issue for Domino who
actually takes on the identity of one of
them this version of Domino comes to the
primary Marvel Universe from an
alternate future and joins a new
incarnation of the mutant Liberation
Front founded by cable and former
x-force team made to shatter star of all
the alternate dominoes that this one is
the coolest not only just a skilled
mercenary make great use of straights
armor but longtime readers love seeing
Domino and body her best friend's
arch-nemesis and evil clone thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]